here we go again against the young bird
let's see we had this recently when I
really like my position have not
refreshed my head knowledge at all so we
have to and let's just hope it turns out
alright so what's that 96 now think it
was me I'd read really remember okay
queenie 425 this kind of thing yeah i
know that this is right but i don't know
why this is one of those funny
situations so it was critics here and
queen cheeks he just takes it
ok after to this writer Queen a want
this the counter play that I'm hoping
for and here what is this if I go 95 and
takes you three at the end at the end a
special page six always huh if I play
Queen a one just like that you will
castle so I guess 95 of course this is
not the kind of position you want
against the yard bird because it's such
a good attacking player but anyway it
provides for an interesting game that
this matches I think Liam Bishop age 6
i'm going to play 97 so I'm grabbing
this here let's see if I go wow if I got
kounya one now what is this move you
still bishop age six and if I take hmm
and Queen a one just back got a new one
whoa okay I mean he's got some kind of
attack but my pawns are dangerous what
happens if i just take it check I just
take it and play like before I just not
caring at all am I getting checkmated
bishop age 697 I don't know okay I'm
just going to play this and hope for
hope for the best he also has 95 but 95
thought 95 we near 10 TCS rupee one
rookie 123 is this helping I don't know
yeah I might have I might be able to
irritate him quite a bit them or not
Queen a one rupee 123 look f1
well if he goes night age 7 i'm playing
night d7 anyway so what about c3 just
c3m and at the end he has this but i
would have queen a one whenever he goes
bishop age 60 that's not really a big
deal okay and i'm just going to push
push things him so let's say yeah I go
97 now I have to do this any bishop age
six I have the maid so okay and now
queen a one for the pin and then be
three
okay i might be able to take that at the
end so be three anyway I have Queen f4
so let's do this so be three
Fisher time version today I have to play
this anyway what a cool game as usual
truly yeah really really tough and maybe
he can play Knight f6 and takes Queen f8
stuff like that and then grab grab the
queen but my hands are pretty quick so
probably not working I think some kind
of bishop age 6 is probably coming this
one okay I thought I thought that'd be
too now I should do the trick but it's
got 97 if I sacrifice the Queen actually
for be too I know he's got he's got them
he's got clean age six at the end
I have no time shoot my txt seven maybe
but I think I can take on c1 it should
be ok on my g6 this is actually
threatening Queen g8 made that could be
the winner for him could be a queen g8
made do I have anything that I can do
against this cake screen shakes and then
Bishop edge six comes this check so that
seems to win 96 maybe Queen a 300k that
I didn't expect that ok this one earned
this one
check on g8 King f8 check to the 72 c 6
am I escaping here no time check check
snow check here Chad absolutely no check
now you will burn on time very likely
Queen g1 would be good if I can get that
in check check
hmm check okay check what's up Jackie
had one yeah of course I was winning
there somehow but wow what a what a wild
ride so chan so how was that winning
exactly let's see nie Dage several okay
the engine says white is winning that's
surprising I think this is surprising
with the pawns going down okay after at
least I would somewhere here I don't
believe it come on and so with this and
it's a draw with Knight f6 and night
f-89 f8b 297 cakes okay so so this is a
draw ok this is I can the second cannot
understand with some kind of Perpetual
losing would be surprising in my book so
check and what happens here Wow yeah
okay this is this he has to do 95 so b3
is regarded as better by the engine here
night each soul 87 rookie won a spare
tire carrier this is 0 this is a blitz
came
here too I was actually briefly thinking
about this but he has this move no I can
play this but it doesn't really doesn't
really help ok that's it simply not
working so this is right 97 and now i
have to take on c1 i really have no
alternative there does this make any
sense by the way check wins for white
oops so the jackal is here ok know it
check this this in Bishop d7 now oh this
is interesting this is this is probably
the way to force the draw and somewhat
more human man like each other probably
wouldn't have made it with the time now
ok but Jackie this is still a draw check
Getty I'm winning with Bishop e8 wave
guy I've got five seconds so I mean yeah
I am a queen up so check check check
check yeah it's like minus 20 or so
anyway he wanted to win on time and who
for whatever what kind of a crazy game I
mean I also would have continued their
with why
I mean you never know if there's some
kind of I mean I don't expect him to
offer draw anything it's just a complete
mess IAM and i have no time and this is
due to the effect that it is so
complicated to play that you have to
spend some time i also every i should
really look at those lines because it's
kind of weird to to play that and don't
know how it how it continues here 95 by
the way it's very strong for what the
computer points out as now i'm not
really in time to save this Bishop
because of bishop age five hmm yeah i
have to look at this opening okay well
thanks for watching